la Unión Europea está Ahora más que
nunca decidida revitalizar las
relaciones con América Latina y con los
países del Caribe y esto explica esta
comunicación presentada hoy por parte de
la comisión europea Bruselas que quiere
apostar porque 2023 sea el año en que se
puedan revitalizar estas relaciones
entre ambos bloques y para empezar
considera que la relación entre la Unión
Europea y los países de la comunidad de
Estados latinoamericanos y caribeños
debe ser de carácter permanente por lo
tanto pide por ejemplo que haya
reuniones de carácter permanente cada
dos años entre que se puedan alternar
entre reuniones de cancilleres y de
jefes de estado y de gobierno el
objetivo es acabar con casos como el
actual por ejemplo en que hace ya 8 años
en que no se celebra una reunión de alto
nivel entre la Unión Europea y los
países de la celac el jefe de la
diplomacia Europea y admitido que ambas
regiones en los últimos años han vivido
de espaldas una a la otra a pesar de ser
socios naturales pero lo que se quiere
apostar es pasar de ser socios naturales
a ser socios por elección y por ello se
habla de fortalecer también las
relaciones comerciales apostar por los
acuerdos comerciales por ejemplo con el
bloque de mercosur un acuerdo que se
cerró por ejemplo en 2019 pero que ahora
mismo faltará un cuestiones técnicas
está a la espera de contrapropuestas por
parte de los países del mercosur para
apostar también por en contra de la
deforestación y apostar a favor del
medio ambiente también el acuerdo con
chile recientemente firmado que en que
se apuesta también por materiales
críticos Como por ejemplo el litio y
también el acuerdo con México que
también falta firmar por todo ello la
Unión Europea también quiere también
fortalecer la inversión muy importante a
través de su plan de inversiones el
conocido como global Gateway también
para hacer frente a la conocida como
ruta de la seda China
y Esther recuperemos una cuestión que
usted mencionaba hace un momento y es
precisamente las cumbres entre la Unión
Europea y la celac ya hay una prevista
para este Julio porque es prioritaria
que se va a abordar
Sí así es esta comunicación lo que
pretende es formar parte ser base de
estas discusiones de esta cumbre de la
celac del 17 y 18 de julio que va a
tener lugar aquí en Bruselas se espera
que haya el mayor número de líderes
europeos y también de líderes de la
celac es una Cumbre que no se celebra
desde hace 8 años una anomalía segura
desde Bruselas y por ello Bruselas
quiere sobre todo que se convierta en el
gran empuje en gran la ventana o de
oportunidad de fortalecer estas
relaciones con esta Cumbre se espera
para empezar dar el empuje definitivo al
acuerdo con mercosur también poder
fortalecer más relaciones con países
clave de la región Como por ejemplo
Brasil y México para poderse encontrar
de forma más permanente con este
documento también se espera que como
base de estas discusiones de esta Cumbre
es que se pueda dar una importante de
que ahora mismo Europa no puede vivir de
espaldas a la región en el contexto
geopolítico actual especialmente en la
Guerra de Ucrania que la región pueda
ser también un socio indiscutible el
luchar contra la agresión por parte de
Rusia y la invasión de Ucrania también
se asegura que este puede ser el punto
clave para fortalecer también las
relaciones de inversión y que esta
Cumbre se convierta en el gran empuje
para fortalecer estas relaciones a
partir de ahora